Hales gun bros my name is Pierre PAH and
today I have some very exciting news if
you remember about a month ago I made a
video saying let's make a game back then
the game looked like this it was just a
skeleton of a game pretty much and we
asked you bros to leave us suggestions
we got an overwhelming amount of
response from you bros and it's super
cool to see how involved you are in this
game because it's your game after all so
I have here an update on how the game
looks like we're gonna play through one
of the levels of the game [ __ ] seals
man you know God and we're all ice
blocks okay it's good we can start from
the beginning Oh God
raining meteors of ice happens every
time I go to the North Pole
Oh G sky I don't want to mess up now oh
my god oh my god ah yes so yeah this is
still in development so don't judge you
too harshly but I think the game looks
absolutely beautiful it plays super nice
other Minds it's the studio who's
working on it and then we're working so
hard on it
it really shows that that they're
they're working hard on to make this the
best game that it could be beat up I
shed and what are you doing he hit me
sim barrows tag me up again damn barrels
they keep tying up those sharks man
don't worry I got this good why are you
so slippery damn sharks and all this so
slippery I don't want to show too much
of the game but there will be other
youtubers in the game that was something
that you bros really suggested jack is
gonna be part of it mark is gonna be
part of it ken is gonna be part of it
and of course my day is gonna be part of
it and she's gonna be a character which
I can change to right now hey have the
Gary nem met oh damn barrels what are
you doing here I want to see if I can
actually beat this level it's so hard
Shannon I saved you damn Shannon why are
you so slippery I kind of hope I die too
because something happens when you die
and it's it's it's beautiful all right
[ __ ] barrels I have one life left
two more Shannon's come on I got it no
not the Illuminati anything but the
Illuminati yes hearts hearts hearts here
we go
kinda like playing as much yet alright
let's change back to me I don't have any
abilities right now but there will be
and they will be awesome we got one more
Shannon baby can we do wait come on come
on come on come on come on yes thank you
now I oh my god is cinnamon toast Ken oh
my god what are you doing in a place
like theirs I'm American I'm gonna quest
to stop these damn barrels hey take me
out of your buckets it sad to breathe in
there alright I forgot you were in here
they're actually perfect timing Stephano
I'm stuck down there I need your
guidance I got an idea
attach me to the rope and bear witness
to my power nice
of course teamwork what about the bugs
oh they can just jump alright that's
cool guys yes so that's a brief
introduction to the game there will be
different stuff to do in the levels
here's the map duck island that's the
one we played and here you can see some
powers you can unlock the brofist 500
broke lines I'm so so excited for this
game Bros you have no idea so we're
hoping to have this release by summer
for you bros and it's still in
development so please keep leaving
suggestions on stuff you want to see in
the game so we can make it as best as
possible for you browse cuz that's
really the goal here beyond anything I
also want to say thank you so much to
outer minds they're so cool to work with
if you want you can follow them on
Twitter and you can follow a development
of the game you can tweet them directly
and tell them how they're doing so we
also like key bros vote for what the
title of the game should be and drumroll
please
PewDiePie legend of the brofist
alright bros thank you so much for
watching and like I said it's a dream of
mine to be part of a project like this
so thanks so much for all everything you
do and making all these stuff cool stuff
happen with that being said thank you
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video
stay awesome rest